welcome back everyone for our uh
discussion session following uh
Professor um Alex pazo's talk yesterday
and I am delighted to introduce our
conversant for um this afternoon
Professor Gila share of the University
of California at San Diego uh we are
delighted to have you here and Alex we
are delighted to have you back
um and uh as a philosophy Professor her
research interests um have focused on
the foundational issues in epistemology
the philosophy of logic and the theory
of Truth her books include the bounds of
logic a generalized Viewpoint from MIT
press epistemic friction and essay on
knowledge truth and logic from Oxford
University press and logical consequence
from the Cambridge University press
she's currently working on a book
provisionally titled truth as a human
value which sounds fascinating which
offers a reconception of the philosophy
of Truth in light of the post-truth
crisis so without further Ado uh let me
invite uh Professor gilashar to take the
floor
thank you
okay I would like first to thank Priya
for inviting me to be a discussion and
I'd like to thank Alex for an extremely
interesting talk yesterday I also
listened to some of the other talks on
your web page and they are really
fascinating
uh so I tagging by short introduction
there is much more to logic than
recognized and this is a citation from
Alex
now I agree with most of the things that
Alex said says about true about sorry
about logic
there is much more to logic than
commonly recognized one of the things is
that logic is not finite in ways it is
commonly thought to be in addition to a
bottom up way of understanding logic
based on the way we commonly use it in
everyday discourse there is also a
top-down theoretical understanding of
logic that shows that logic is stronger
than commonly thought a very important
theoretical consideration of this kind
is the strong degree of invariance of
logic that Alex talked about this has to
do with the topic neutrality and other
special features of logic such as
formality necessity and generality
but there are also a significant
relations between purely logical or
deductive inferences and non-logical
non-deductive inferences not all good
inferences I agree with Alex are logical
since I agree with Alex I won't
criticize him but I approach logic from
some different perspective than him so I
will try to broaden the perspective
hence the significance of what Alex said
about logic and I will ask him if he
agrees with this broadening among other
things I will address the question of
Truth in logic and I will try to give a
tentative answer to two of the questions
that Priya asked Alice yesterday what is
special to the structure of mathematics
compared to physics and why and I would
add whether mathematics can't be
affected by experimentation
let's start with truth Alex gave a
single example of a logical influence or
implication I will use them
interchangeably here
the influence is if a then B if B then C
therefore if a then C and here it is in
symbols too
now is it true that this is a logically
valid inference or take this inference
for some x p x or QX for all X not p x
therefore for some x q X
is this is it true that this inference
is logically valid
now the above inferences seem to be
logically valid but is it true that they
are logically valid
and if it is why and Does this answer
extend to infinitary inferences like the
ones that Alex talked about
some people say that there is no truth
and falsehood enlarge it logic is just a
game
and like all games The Logical game has
its rules which tell us when we win and
when we lose but this has nothing to do
with truth for example the later
Wittgenstein said that logic is a
language game khanap said that logic is
nearly conventional there is no right
and wrong in logic there is only what we
like or what is convenient
this leads to a properties to relativist
and pluralist views of logic Alex I
should note is not is an anti-pluralist
he is a modest about logic his book is
titled the one true logic
now even if you believe that there is
truth and falsehood in logic and that
it's true that the above inferences are
logically valid the question arises why
or in virtue of what is it true that
they are logically vague
some philosophers perhaps most
philosophers say that this is a matter
of language logical inferences are
analytic English users treat them as
logically valid
when we put these two approaches
together we arrive at the view that
logical inferences are just winning
moves in a in a language game and this
was
wittgenstein's View
what I want to show is that logic is
never is neither a game nor grounded
merely in language I will do this first
in a bottom top Way by an example
plane logic is not just a language game
logic must be constrained by the world
truth in the world can be a matter of
life and death in logic not just reading
or losing a game and being construed by
the world makes logic similar to physics
and other Sciences
here is a short story that demonstrates
this
Abe is a young naive student at
University X he takes seriously
everything his professors especially
he's more extravagant professors that
teaching
one day and no logic Professor joins
Apes University and he is eccentric
extravagant and exciting as a likes the
no Professor tells students that logic
is nothing more than a game
he shares with them one of his favorite
rules which belongs to a new
non-traditional logic game he invented
he calls this rule modus dafka now dafka
is a Hebrew word which means willfully
spitefully deliberately doing the
opposite of what you are expected to do
and the rule modus dafka is the
following
first we have a premise if a then not B
then we have the premise a and we
conclude B
Abe is excited about modus dafka he
decides to follow it in his everyday
life
modus dafka is not a traditional rule of
inference
it superficially similar to an instance
of a traditional logical rule modus
spell names which would say the instance
would say if a then not b a therefore
not b but it's different
standing on the side of a busy road in
town one day aim is getting ready to
cross it his parents taught him if a car
is coming don't cross the road
it takes one to be true it is the
conditional command analog of a true
sentence hence essentially true
any checks whether a car is coming and
sees that one is coming indeed many are
remembering is no exciting teachers
favorite logical role MD if a then not b
a therefore B A crosses the road
a dice
MD may be an exciting rule but it does
not work in the world
in contrast rules that are grounded in
the world like modus ponens do motor
spawning opponents is grounded in the
world it says if a then not b a
therefore not B head eight followed MP
instead of MD you would not have crossed
the road and would not have been killed
by a car at least at that time
now this was a bottom-up argument for
the claim that logic is constrained by
the world
but can we establish it also using a
top-down theoretical argument
can we establish this by an argument
about the nature of logic of the kind
used by Alex to establish the infinitary
character of logic
I think we can but first I would like to
address the methodological issue of
providing a top-down theoretical
foundation for logic is it possible to
provide a foundation for logic many
philosophers believe that it's
impossible
to provide a foundation for ex they say
you have to go outside X but we cannot
go outside logic we cannot make any step
in thought without using logic a
foundation for logic will be circular
this was the view of the young
Wittgenstein and many past and present
philosophers shared
I don't why
the methodology used in foundational
studies in philosophy the traditional
one is foundationalism
it says that in order to provide the
foundation for knowledge all units of
knowledge have to be grounded in
something which is lower than them in
the foundational hierarchy until in the
end they are all grounded in the base
the problem is that there's nothing
lower than the base so it is in
principle impossible to ground the base
since everything depends on the base
nothing can be grounded in the case of
logic it's more direct because everyone
puts logic in the base
what I believe is that there is more
than one foundational methodology and a
more fruitful methodology is what I call
foundational holism here we have our
system of knowledge different branches
and different parts are connected to the
world in different ways in many places
and they are all connected also among
themselves in order to a and write that
knowledge or to give a foundation for
knowledge we have to ground it on the
one hand in the world through these all
connections and we can also help
ourselves by utilizing the connections
the internet connections between fields
of knowledge the process is dynamic and
it goes in a back and forth manner once
we have a tentative foundation for
something we move to another part of our
system of knowledge use new resources
that we got in the meantime and we
examine uh found our original Foundation
Whenever there is circularity it is
usually temporary and partial it is
partial because we always use many
sources in order to find something for
example in the case of logic we use
philosophy mathematics genuine knowledge
common sense besides using logic and
it's all also temporary because we
always come back and re-examine our
foundation and assume different things
and put aside things we assume in the
past
so using the foundation and holistic
methodology one way to go about
providing a foundation for logic is this
we start with two observations about
knowledge one for one reason or another
human beings are interested in knowing
the world as it is but to such knowledge
does not come to them automatically and
in many cases it is quite difficult to
arrive in this is largely due to the
limitations of our cognitive resources
one result of these imitations is that
we are prone to error this is where
truth enters into the picture we need
truth we need a norm or a standard of
Truth to avoid error
another result is that we need shortcuts
we cannot discover each facet of the
world individually
this is where methods of inference come
into play We would especially benefit
from having a genuine method for
arriving from truths that we already
know to truth that we don't yet know the
function of logic is to provide such a
method
now because our goal is true theories of
the world it's very important that
logical inference translates truth truth
in the world from premises to conclusion
and it's also very desirable that logic
provide a strong method of transmitting
truths one that works in all or most
fields of knowledge and even for cases
we have not encountered yet but might
encounter in the future that is counter
factual cases
so the task of logic is to provide a
method of inference that transmits truth
from premises to conclusion with a
considerable modern force and generality
a logically implies B if and only if a
translates truth to be necessarily and
in all Fields but is this possible
I think it is and a reason as follows
if one in the world
if one the world has certain features
that occur everywhere including all
parts of the world with the different
fields of knowledge study and including
counter factual situations
and if two these features are governed
by laws which are both highly General
and highly necessary
then we could use our knowledge of these
laws to create a general and necessary
method of inference a method for
transmitting truths from sentences that
are true in the world to other sentences
that are true in the world expanding our
knowledge to the letter in one failed
swoop
this is what we are looking for features
or properties F1 F2 in the world such
that looking from the bottom up it is a
law that F1 necessitates F2 so in the
world a situation C1 that has F1
necessitate situation C2 that has F2 and
if S1 is true just in case C1 is the
case and S2 is true just in case C2 is
the case then the necessitation and the
level of the world ensures that the
truth of S1 strongly guarantees the
truth of S2 and this is the basis for
the influence S1 logically implies S2
now are there such properties like F1
and F2 yes
formal properties of the sky properties
like identity complementation Union
intersection cardinality properties such
as at least one having finite
cardinality n Etc
note that at least one is the same
property as non-emptiness which is the
existential quantifier property to say
that there is at least one p is the same
as saying p is not empty which is the
same as saying there is an X such that p
x
now all the standard logical constants
and the properties they denote are
intuitively formal and this explains how
and why
standard logical
implications work for example take the
implication for some x a X or BX for all
X not BX therefore for some x a X for
the prime the premises transmit choose
necessarily to the conclusion because in
the world there's a formal law which
says that the non-emptiness of any Union
of any property is P1 and P2 plus The
Emptiness of P2 here B is empty
necessitates the non-emptiness of P1
this explains why the above influence
transmits truth from premises to
conclusion and does so in all fee and
with strong necessity
or feed for example in a case of the
natural numbers A and B can be positive
and negative a properties of being
positive and negative there is at least
one number which is positive or negative
no number natural number is negative
therefore at least one is positive and
in the field of the American Presidents
uh this could be the properties of being
a man and a woman so there is at least
one American president which is a man or
a woman and so far there are no American
Presidents which are women therefore
there is at least one which is a man
now it is important to recognize that
there are more formal properties than
former laws and former laws and more
formal laws than those underlying the
inferences of standard large okay this
correlates with the point Alex made
yesterday
for example the property is is infinite
as in countable the second level
properties are formal
and
uncountable P necessitates infinite p is
a formal law
so the inference uncountably many X DX
therefore Phi Infinity many x p x also
transmits truth from premise to
conclusion with a strong modern false
hence it is logically valuable we have
done two things one we have provided a
foundation for standard logical
inferences and two we expanded standard
logic based on the same Foundation
but we also did a third thing we
expanded logical inferences to
influences the deal with Infinities such
inferences are not recognized by
standard logic
this is another aspect of the infinitary
character of logic and as we shall
shortly see it is equivalent to the
infinitary character of Alex's
infinitary logic which has to do with
infinitely long conjunctions
disjunctions and quantifications
but in order to reach this result and in
order to further systematize our
foundation of logic we need to
systematically characterize formality
formal properties
and this leads us to the fascinating
topic of invariance that Alex talks
talked about
in variance is a central topic of
interest in both Science and Mathematics
but the invariants used in the
foundation of logic is a bit different
it is property invariance let me explain
every property whatsoever has some
degree of invariance what does this mean
it means that every property Remains the
Same under sum one to one and onto
Replacements of individuals
example the property is a human
if we replace individuals which are men
by individuals which are women in a
one-to-one manner the property is a
human will not notice it is in variant
under such replacements
most properties however are not
invariant under all one-to-one and onto
Replacements of individuals for example
is a human is invariant under
Replacements of men by women but not
under Replacements of men by numbers
when we replace Biden by the number one
and Trump by the number two and Obama by
the number three and so on will replace
the properties a human by the property
is a number
but some properties are invariant under
all one-to-one and onto Replacements of
individuals for example self-identity
by the self-identited calendar is one
Trump is self-identical and so is too
and similarly Obama and three
indeed maximally maximally invariant
properties are invariant not just under
one-to-one Replacements of actual
individuals but also under one-to-one
Replacements of counterfactual
individuals for example identity is
invariant under all one-to-one and all
onto Replacements of actual
counterfexual individuals if we replace
Biden by Hamlet for example we also
replace an individual which is identical
to itself and only to Itself by an
individual which is identical to itself
and only to itself identity is not
affected by such a replacement
in fact all the formal properties in our
examples above are of this kind
consider is non-empty the existential
quantifier property take any domains
with the same number of individuals for
example D1 is Biden from Obama and d2123
now replace the members of D1 by members
of D2 in a one-to-one manner for example
is above next take any property of
objects in D1 say is a Democratic
president
this property satisfies non-emptiness in
D1
but also its image under the one-to-one
replacement is non-empty its image is
the property a being an odd numbers
Biden is correlated with one and Obama
with three and this property also is not
empty so non-emptiness does not notice
is in volume under this replacement
and this holds generally
let us call properties that are
invariant under all one-to-one and onto
Replacements of actual counter factual
individuals maximally invariant
properties
we seem to have two very interesting
results one all the standards logical
properties the properties denoted by The
Logical constants are maximally in value
chill other properties including
infinitistic properties such as
infinitely many and uncountably many are
also maximally in value
we also have results that enable us to
give a precise definition of formality
a property p is maximally invariant
infinitely if it is invaliant under all
isomorphism what does this mean
for example identity is invariant and
there does not distinguish between any
isomorphic structures of the form D
domain and a pair of individuals a b
a is identical to B and the structure d
a b is isomorphic to the structure D
prime a prime B Prime if and only if a
prime is identical to B Prime
now intuitively a property is isomorphic
isomorphism invariant if and only if it
is highly structural
it follows from one and two that a
property is maximally invaliant if and
only if it is highly structural
and seems to be formal is intuitively to
be highly structural we now have a
precise definition of formality property
p is format is by definition P is
maximally in value
another interesting result is if a
property is formal the laws governing it
are highly necessary
reason
if a property does not distinguish
between any actual counterfactual
individuals its laws cannot distinguish
between them either
if they hold in any domain of actual
counterfactual individuals they hold in
all domains of actual counterfactual
individuals hence they are necessary
it follows all implications based on
formal laws are necessary
this explains why all the standard
logical implications as well as
infinitistic implications like
uncountered uncountably many xpx
therefore infinitely many X PX are
necessary they transmit truth from
premises to conclusion with a very
strong model Force hence they satisfy
the requirements and logical
implications
I.E they are logically valid next we
arrive at McGee's result that Alex
relied on yesterday
a property is formal even only if it is
definable in the logic L infinity
infinity
this means that all infinitary
implications in Alex's sense are logical
finally there is an interesting result
concerning mathematics all higher level
mathematical properties are former
now since all mathematical individuals
and their lower level mathematical
properties are correlated with higher
level mathematical properties all of
mathematics is essentially
format what do I mean by this
correlation for example the number one
which is a mathematical individual is
correlated with the second level
mathematical property exactly one as in
there is exactly one Moon of Earth and
this is how it's usually used in science
let me conclude with a few results
concerning the difference and
similarities between mathematics and
science
differences between mathematics and
science and this addresses the points
that Priya raised yesterday
the fact that mathematic mathematics is
formal maximally invariant explains what
is special about mathematics mathematics
has maximal invariance hence its laws
are highly necessary
physical properties are not maximally in
value therefore their laws have a weaker
necessity than the logical and
mathematical laws for example physical
laws distinguish between numbers and
physical objects they hold of the former
and of the later but not of the former
because physical experiments concern
physical properties which are not
maximally invariant they are generally
not relevant to mathematics they don't
make a difference to mathematics
mathematics does not notice them it is
blind to them
on the other hand there are also
similarities between mathematics and
science as Alex pointed out or in the
spirit of what he pointed out a although
mathematical properties I'm sorry
physical properties
are not maximally in value
some physical properties like being
subject to gravity have a fairly strong
degree of involence they are environed
under all one-to-one and onto
Replacements of physically possible
individuals any replacement of physical
individuals will get you from individual
which is subject to gravity to an
individual which is subject to gravity
and even in the contextual case say a
second moon of Earth that will be the
case a second moon of Earth will be
subject to gravity
therefore there are laws also have a
fairly strong degree of necessity
B Because physical objects and
properties have formal properties for
example the property of being a moon of
Earth the physical property has the
formal property of having cardinality
one
mathematics and logic which are formal
theories are widely applicable to
physics they deal with proformal poverty
is which
are properties of physical objects and
physical properties
this gives a no answer to wigner's
famous question about the unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics and I would
add logic in the Natural Sciences
the fact that physical objects have
formal properties and are governed by
former laws explains also how sometimes
physical results are relevant to
mathematics whenever we get a new
refutation of a scientific conjecture
there is a possibility that the mistake
concerns formal assumptions we made
concerning the physical situation this
gives us a motivation to re-examine our
formal assumptions and our background
mathematical theories more generally
I will end with a question to Alex my
philosophical understanding of logic and
Mathematics supports and expands many of
your results but people can agree on
some things yet give them different
philosophical explanations
are these philosophical explanations of
your result in agreement with your own
General philosophical conception of
logic and if not what is your take on
the philosophical Foundation of logic
logical influence which underlies from
your point of view your results thank
you
thank you so much Gila for engaging both
with Alex and many of the questions mine
and others that came up yesterday
so um Alex the floor is first yours to
um
to bring up any points of uh agreement
or disagreement or Nuance that you would
like us to learn from a conversation
with Gila
thank you very much
very careful and insightful discussion
as as Priya said both of my talk of her
questions and and the the subject matter
um I think I should start by saying that
Gila and I are so
um overwhelmingly in agreement
that we can have a discussion that we
can have a discussion of our differences
but that should not obscure the fact
that we agree on so much of the terrain
here and in particular we agree on this
key uh feature of logic that it's uh
infinite most technically infinitely
um that we both discussed uh today uh
and that puts us in a in a small
minority actually uh today
um uh in in today's sort of intellectual
climate
um but nonetheless we we don't we both
think it for for Fairly similar reasons
although um Gila she indicated today
um adds I I would characterize it this
way as it adds another layer uh to it a
sort of deeper layer
um than the one that that I
um mentioned the reasons that I gave she
sort of gives a foundation as she talked
as she said in her foundational from her
foundational hopeless perspective I'm
happy to to open the floor to other
people before we start talking about
those small differences because I want
to emphasize that they are uh small and
we will get Tequila's question to me at
the end but I think it might be better
to ask other people to intervene uh
rather than emphasize some rather small
differences
okay great so
so I think I'm gonna take the bait and
ask a few
um a few sort of clarifying questions so
I mean I have a couple but let me start
off with the one so from what you've
said that
potentially the difference between say
physics and Mathematics arises is it
really the existence of laws but then
laws are not really quite reliable in
the same way as proofs right
um so the physical logs and laws are not
quite the analog
but a law because the law is is not a
permanently stable and Beyond reproach
um sort of end-all like a proof is in
terms of a description
so I was curious about whether
um you know what is the role of laws
from when you control it I got a sense
that somehow laws are very much part of
what distinguishes so you know the law
of gravitation
um the fact that it is
indisputable in a certain way is makes
it very much like a proof and that
that's
but
um what am I missing something is there
but you know I'm not entirely sure if um
yeah okay so the way I think about it is
like this and
you know laws in all fields are
associated with some properties so you
say we have the laws of gravity is the
laws of motions they are associated with
properties in the uh in logic although
we talked about inferences we also have
laws the laws of non-contradiction the
laws of identity the laws of excluded
middle of this Junction and so on so
they are always associated with
properties now
um especially in physics today in the
philosophy of physics I'm not in physics
I don't know how it is in physics but in
the philosophy of physics and many
people question whether there are laws
at all
and this is a big question
and one of the things that I I want to
emphasize that one similarity that there
is between logical and mathematical laws
and and physical laws is that
some physical principles have a very
high degree of involence it's not as
high as a degree of invariance
of logical or mathematical laws but the
physical laws are generally
associated with properties that have a
high degree of imbalance for example you
don't have a low of the mountain Everest
which is you know being a mountain
Everest has very low degree of
invalience you have laws of gravity of
mass of motion of things like this that
have a very high degree of invariance
I cannot agree that the degree of
invariance but there is also there is a
domain of validity right which you do
not have in mathematical laws of
mathematics if you will or laws of logic
if you will right
um you know so again you know coming
back to Newton and Einstein there's a
domain of validity where a Newtonian
description is not only sufficient but
it's excellent and it is enough right
sufficient necessary and enough to
describe the world and motions and
everything that we can experience
however that is not the last word on so
it says a domain of validity and there's
a domain Beyond which it's no longer
valid right so the conditionality to
laws in physics like domain of validity
um that you for properties which you do
not have right in mathematics like a
proof is a result that is truth that is
stable and there are no conditionals
there right
well not exactly at least in my view
okay
groups in mathematics uh as Alex
mentioned yesterday are usually based on
certain axioms and so there are based on
seven Theory which is its identity is
determined by its axioms and um if you
accept the axioms the proof is approved
right but there is a question of whether
you accept the axioms and in the same
way that in mathematics you know when
you look at things in a certain
perspective in certain scope it seems
that the laws are perfect but then when
we look in a broader perspective you see
no they are not perfect they work where
they agree with the narrow perspective
but not the broader perspective the same
thing can happen also in mathematics and
in fact even in logic and one of my
colleagues
um Penelope Madi and you know brought a
very interesting example she's not the
first but she worked it out I think
beautifully
that also connects logic to physics and
that's the question of quantum mechanics
where are some physicists and
philosophers of logic thought that the
microscopic domain turns out to be
formally different from the macroscopic
domain and that for example it's it may
it's not Boolean and that might require
that we have a different Logic for you
now for me it's a possibility I would
not say that this is actually the case
but I think in principle it's possible
so in the same way that you moved from
Lutheran to Einstein we might move from
Boolean algebra to some kind and Boolean
logic to some other kind of logic now
it's less likely there are fewer uh it's
there's a smaller likelihood of changes
in logic because of the enormous
invariance of its principles most
discoveries it doesn't pay attention to
but that's not always the case so if
even in this way I think the more
similarities but also differences if I
may pitching at this point and I also
wanna I wanna follow up on this but I
also want to pick up a question in the Q
a by Joe
um so from my point of view mathematics
is a fallible Enterprise like any other
and
um what I said yesterday about
non-deductive in inference in
mathematics in a way is supported by
that thought if deductive inference was
somehow infallible it was just this
infallible way of getting you from truth
to truth there would be something
special about it but
um but but but I mean but to say to say
that there's a sort of bias here in just
the choice of terminology the word proof
is a success word so of course if you've
got to prove it it's successful but the
human practice of mathematics is a
highly um valuable one so Joel in the um
uh Joel in the in the chat brought up
the uh Wells uh proof attempted proof in
93 of Farmer's Last Theorem
which um was fallacious there was there
was a gap which he then took a couple of
years to fix one of his uh a colleague
um and I think that just that that is
just an example on a kind of grand and
you know highly publicized scale of the
fact that
um mathematics is a human endeavor and
people get things wrong
um so it there isn't anything
uh I mean mathematics it's easier to
spot mistakes that is true and um it's
um there is perhaps a higher degree of
certainty but it's not a 100 and it's uh
you know it's a human fallible
Enterprise like like any other just a
little bit more along along the uh the
range yeah and I will also add to what
Alex said that you know and the case of
why spoof ended up being a success but
in Logic for example we have this case
in which on the one hand frager
revolutionized logic or maybe with a
background of other people around him
but Russian discovered a paradox in his
logic and air or a fatal error and this
could not be corrected at the same time
there are still things that can be done
and so Russell himself built a logic
that included many of Friday's
principles but not the principles that
led to the Paradox and then there were
other ways of doing it like sets Theory
axiomatic sex Theory and first order
logic and so on and so in mathematics
and having I mean it's not that you
always fix it I mean it can really
sometimes you can be completely wrong
and have to leave something uh reject
something as a result
great thanks
um let me see uh
if there are any other questions
so just to answer Joe uh Joel had a
second part to his question there could
be a flaw in um in even in the patched
up proof I mean it was 100 pages long
highly sophisticated proof uh and what
we don't think there is but they could
that could well be well be
um in fact there's a sort of interesting
story of a great mathematician
vladimirsky who um who was a field
medalist and he was so shocked by what a
big a major error in a proof
um that he decided that it was about
time that mathematics
um formalized its proofs and they were
sort of much more sophisticated computer
theorem Checkers
um in order to to eliminate Aaron as
much as possible
um and that has helped but but but it
hasn't gone all the way because I just
don't think you can go um all the way
so that um actually as we wait for
somebody else to I mean that was
actually going to be my um my question
that is it true that I'm curious why you
said you know
um find it in it that a computer will
not be able to invaluably all the time
discover flaws
okay so the computer will improve
um efficiency yeah
um and but you know it is a machine like
any other and that has to be tested that
could be that could be uh problems and
it's also there's also going to be sort
of bounds on capacity right so maybe for
short proofs it's going to be able to
cover them but but very long ones maybe
we won't be able to have for physical
reasons of you know physical for
physical reasons not be able to build
one that that manages to to check look
very long groups and so on sure it's
many steps in the right direction right
um and you've got you've gotta you've
got to also think about how you feed a
human proof into a computer right
um how do you translate it in such a way
that the computer can check it
um it that process has not been
mechanized and that is a possible source
of error as well right so I mean there
aren't
um there aren't sort of uh you know AI
algorithms that are you know so in
physics for example
um they recently demonstrated that
um you know for Kepler's laws they said
that if you fed a computer just the
positions of you know planetary
positions orbits the information that
Kepler really knew at the time
then what could the computer infer from
that data of course you have to you have
to request that it recovers some kind of
correlation or law and then surprise
surprise of course it does recover
Kepler's laws and that was very
surprising to us right in the community
but somehow because you know many
reasons right one of course is like the
the sort of the the unique creative sort
of the you know having it allows us to
keep intact this whole idea of human
creativity and the individual and so on
so forth right and um but I'm curious
whether there have been attempts
to harness AI
to
um you know to mathematize
the notion of proofs and other
algorithms
um I think there was a project called
the bacon project wasn't there I mean I
don't know if that about that particular
one but the answer to your question is
yes and in fact there's lots of um
formal proof uh Checkers and not just
not just that these days they're also
there's also AI that
um suggests theorems so I think there
was an article earlier this year or last
year in the Scientific American or an
analog
um about uh proofs and topology that the
AI um was you know was taught some a bit
of topology about topology and just came
up with not came up with some um
conjectures that it proved itself
so that's definitely
um On The Rise but going back to my
earlier point the way that normal
standard proofs are written uh in a in a
in a journal or communicated in a
lecture room
um they're very wrapped up in human
language in in human modes of thought
and so we are not yet at the point
uh which we can mechanically translate
those and and and completely be sure
that we've checked for the validity that
might come I'm not saying it will not
but we're not there yeah
I actually have a question to pray about
something he mentioned just now and
that's creativity
supposedly as opposed to what computers
are doing so it might be disappointing
if what someone arrived creatively could
arrive it simply by a a computer
approved
um you know in philosophy usually when
people think about creativity they think
about it in terms of some kind of
immediate intuition and psychology also
people talk about in aha moment or
something like this and but it strikes
me that this is not the only form of
creativity
and that we are also creating and also
use intellect not just by this kind of
intuition but ways of figuring out right
and that brings us closer to creativity
closer towards a computer can be can do
but I think that this is also related to
what I talked about earlier about holism
in that one very important aspect in
creativity I think any figuring things
out that we can always switch
perspective we can go always go beyond
the place where we are and look at it
and look at other things and connect
them and may try to figure out things
right this is right so the Dynamics may
be of human creativity is different from
the Dynamics of computers but I think
but yeah but I think that you know so in
physics for example we increasingly know
that
scientists own Narrative of their
discoveries are highly incomplete and
they
um they don't quite reflect
the the range of activities because we
are so fixated on this idea of the known
male genius
and this aha moment right that the
Eureka moment right that
recounting our own personal recounting
of our own discoveries is not reliable
and but what appears to be a robust fact
across questions uh across individuals
um is the fact that the Insight if you
really drill down into what is new what
was the leap what so it turns out that
the the creative leap appears to be the
ability to connect different domains of
knowledge which appear entirely
unrelated at first so we are not just
talking of tools you're not talking of
language we are not talking of
methodologies of Investigation or
anything but really the formal
representations of ideas and properties
of objects in the case of physics across
domains and that it's a language
translation exercise if you will that is
more than just the language it's a
conceptual domain mapping and that we do
when new discoveries are made and you
are right if inherently that is a key
part of what we call human creativity
that is hard to replicate in a computer
because what we feed in is what the
computer operates out of so you would
ultimately need to have a computer that
has a training set in every domain of
knowledge and then see if it can do the
kind of you know connection making and
synthesis that we believe that you know
Human by Minds have the capacity to do
oh yeah I don't know if this is a good
moment to discuss one of the differences
between uh Gila and me and the question
that she raised at the end okay so just
a very briefly
um sort of summarize it uh Gila and I
agree on this very important claim that
logic is infinite but uh and we give
similar sorts of arguments for it but
she she gives it she founds it with
another another let on on another layer
this idea of formal laws and formal
features of of the world
um now I don't disagree with that uh
it's not that I agree with it either
um I am undecided as to whether to say
something like that and I have three
sources of of hesitation so I'll mention
what those sources of hesitation are the
first is really more of a pragmatic one
I think for dialectical purposes
um if we want to convince people that uh
logic is infinite then adding um kind of
the metaphysical layer if you like might
be something it might be a step too far
uh for some people that's not a reason
against it it's just a just a
dialectical Point uh and why it doesn't
feature uh heavily in in my book because
getting them getting people today to
agree that logic is infinite is already
quite a big a big task the second source
of hesitation
um is that in the on the standard
conception of logic model theoretic uh
conception the uh models that we
quantify over when we consider whether
the premises entail the conclusion we
formalize the those in in the logic and
we consider the models of the premises
and see whether all those models are
also models of the conclusion those
models understand understanding do not
include the whole universe right because
they're just they're sets and they're
not the class that is the the
um the whole universe so in a way it's a
it's a little strange to couple that
combine that standard understanding
which can be which is a sun which can be
um adopted on the on the on the infinite
review of logic as well with it's that
it's strange to combine that perhaps
uneasy to combine that with the idea
um that uh logic is about the formal
features because of of of reality if
reality is not actually one of those
models and then the thought third source
of
um hesitation and it's not
um it's not disagreement it's just
hesitation about going that far I I want
to stress is I'm not sure how much
explanation
um you get by saying of the fact that
logic is infinite by adding this layer
of saying that the world has four more
features it seems to be redescribing
um the fact of logic's infinity
in more metaphysical language uh laws
and and structures and and so on I I'm
not saying it doesn't go further it does
seem to
um but but it seems quite close to what
we were saying before to really be a
powerful explanation of it as opposed to
a redescription so those are my three
sources of hesitation Gila I don't
disagree with you I just don't go quite
as far for those for those reasons
yeah and well like that I I understand
very much your first pragmatic
consideration yes a perfectly reasonable
but I do have something to say about the
other reason
now at the other the second reason is
something that was raised for example by
heart we feel
and uh for those of you who are maybe
not familiar with this we live neither
one of us talked about models uh very
much in our uh so far but
um there is the the the standard way of
understanding logical truths and logical
consequence is to say that there is a
totality of models each model represents
either a way that our language could be
or away the world could have been
and uh but
um the non-logical properties change
from mother to model but the logical
properties are fixed so disjunction is
always disjunction identity is always
identity but a property like being a man
in one model it's that property another
it's the property of being a woman or
being an odd number or being an even
number and so on and so what is true in
all models is supposed is said to me
what is logically true what couldn't be
false what is true due to the logical
structure of sentences or logical
meaning of a sentences which is fixed in
all models
now models are usually thought to be
except theoretical a construct
and a model consists of a universe which
is a set
and then
objects and subsets and relations and so
on which represent the properties that
we are talking about in a particular
sentence
and the laws that govern models are the
laws of sex Theory and how many models
there are how many possibilities are
represented by models is the number of
possibilities that can be represented by
sets Inception
now one distinctive aspect of sex theory
is that set theory can represent
s but it cannot represent the totality
of all sets and one might say that what
is really real and is the totality of
all sex
and that said Theory cannot represent
and so mothers say theoretical models do
not represent this either
so truth in all matters is in some way
not truth in all possibilities maybe
even naturally in the real reality
now in my view this is not a conclusive
argument
and the reason is that we need to
distinguish between the general idea and
its implementation of personification
there is another thing about the general
and idea of logic that to be true is to
be true in all formally possible
situations
and setfield
in principal we could have implemented a
different seal Russell for example in
his theory of types didn't use axiomatic
set theory and didn't have this problem
and so I see this just as a matter of
implementation I think the idea is right
but we still need to find an adequate
mathematical theory that will enable us
to implement it precisely
another point which is relevant is that
even if we use set theory there is a
point that was emphasized by McGee and
others that inceptionally itself there
are reflection principles and these
reflection principles say that even
though the totality of sets is not
represented by a set there are so many
sets and so many variations between sets
that it is sufficient to represent any
type of structure including the class
structure so once again there are
questions about this point but the first
point seems to be more important that
you know the problem is in
implementation and not in principle I
wonder what do you think about this Alex
um I I think you could be right
um about that I don't I don't disagree
with that
um but the as I say it's not
disagreement it's hesitation because I
haven't seen uh
a convincing implementation of that yet
that could be my ignorance
um which is why I hesitate to take that
step if they were
um a precise uh cogent in the
implementation that
um undercut all those doubts then I
would be I I I'd join you yeah
immediately
um but and there may be one uh and maybe
we can you know you can imagine one but
but we I haven't quite seen one yet so
that's that's why I'm I'm a little
hesitant yeah yeah and I think it's
partly a matter of how you treat you
know
philosophical results for me you can
have a solid philosophical results even
without having yet
a mathematical implementation for it and
the philosophical results stands at its
own but there are many people who would
not agree and would say we actually need
an implementation in order to
substantiate the philosophical result
yeah so in that way it might be a matter
of sort of temperament almost almost
um on the second point about reflection
I I again I think you're right but again
I mean reflection is you know sensitive
to the language of the set theory and so
on so
and what was your last point I forgot um
my last Point
um was
that that the talk of formal laws uh and
formal structure was in a way uh wasn't
sure how much explanation it was giving
you because it seemed to be restating
some of the points of the Infinity of
logic
um but just putting it in metaphysic
more metaphysical language
and so I didn't I as I see it it wasn't
giving you very much else you know an
explanation a b if B is an explanation
of a it's got to go quite a bit beyond a
and it seemed like saying a in the same
the same sort of thing as a but in a
much more physical much more physical
language metaphysical excuse me
metaphysical language
yeah yeah and
I know this is partly because my
perspective is a little bit more General
epistemic perspective you know knowledge
in general we want to know how the world
is so we want to know whether there are
a formal properties things in the world
have four man properties and we want to
know whether there are four manners that
govern the world this is a question
which is interesting and it said but
it's also a connection to the question
of truth I mean we were talking about
consequence about implication but in
infinitistic logic of the kind you talk
about there are also logical truth and
the question is whether logical truths
are really true and if they are true in
virtue of what they are true I think
that the advantage of going to the world
and say that they are true due to formal
laws that govern the world give you a
straightforward explanation of why they
are true and if you give this up it's
not clear to me how you can establish
truth this is I think the main issue
that bothers me
I I see that thank you yeah
um yeah I mean I think I think I think I
have so far declined to answer that that
question and it is a question that needs
an answer uh I agree I I certainly agree
with it with that
um
yeah okay so I think uh one more
question has showed up in the chat from
Ed Brandon and uh so he asks I don't
think it's an ignorant question uh what
is the relation between valid infinitary
arguments Professor Brazil gave and what
is called mathematical induction
okay
um yeah so mathematical induction the
principle of mathematical induction is a
principle about the natural numbers uh
zero one two three and so on or some
people just start at one and it says
that if zero has a property and secondly
if a number has a property then its
successor also has a property from those
two facts you can infer that every
number has the property
and so uh that's specific to the natural
numbers of course
um it doesn't it doesn't hold in other
domains uh in lots of other domains
right
um so for example if you throw in the
negative integers
um the principle of mathematical
induction isn't going to hold right
because you could have it's starting at
zero and transmitting but but never
getting to the um negative integers
um valid infinite tree arguments however
are completely General and apply to any
subject matter whatsoever
um
so
um it can be about numbers natural
numbers real numbers but also about
physical situations
um whatever whatever you like
there's if Ed if that does not answer
your question then feel free to ask a
follow-up
let me see if there is uh
yeah I don't
um I don't see a follow-up from Ed
Plus
I mean to put it very broadly
mathematical induction is the principle
of mathematical induction specific to
the to arithmetic to the natural numbers
uh logic Infiniti or finite Gila and I
both think it's infinitely applies to
any any kind of
um domain
much broader right yeah yes
uh there is a there is a potential
confusion with the word
um induction here
because because induction is all is used
in all sorts of ways I mean I mean
outside academic uses you know you can
be inducted into the Rock and Roll uh
Hall of Fame
but but even within a philosophy and
Mathematics it's used in different ways
uh and so when I was talking about
non-deductive knowledge
um that's sometimes called inductive
knowledge uh but that can be a bit
confusing so I was I was Keen to just
say non-deductive to not call it
perspective yeah
great so if there are no further
questions
I think we can draw our session to a
close and so let me thank both Gila and
Alex for a wonderful
discussion a great lecture yesterday and
for a really nice uh discussion today a
clarifying sort of points of view points
of convergence and uh and the very few
points of Divergence in your views but
thank you so much for enriching and
teaching us all so much yeah so let's uh
give a round of applause uh to our
speakers today and yeah we're really
deeply grateful to both of you for
coming thanks bye thanks